tengo una función efe que es un mapeo
que va del conjunto x al conjunto y y
también para fines del argumento de este
vídeo voy a suponer algo muy fuerte y
que es que f es invertible con todo lo
que ya ya hemos visto de la
invertibilidad en el vídeo en el vídeo
anterior ahora lo que quiero saber es
qué implicaciones tiene esto de aquí de
que la función sea invertirle sobre la
ecuación fx igual a ye ok es decir
quiero saber si para cada y si para cada
cada vez que me tome yo en el condominio
que represente con mayúscula será que
existe primero la pregunta si existe y
también si existe una única y voy a
ponerlo con con mayúsculas una única
solución
solución de hecho una solución x que se
encuentra en nuestro dominio tal que tal
que fx sea igual allí y el detalle
importante es bueno sí sí es importante
saber si existe pero además es
importante también saber si es única
esta solución ok entonces para dibujarlo
más o menos con con muñequitos vamos a
tener aquí nuestro conjunto x tendremos
aquí nuestro conjunto
y digamos que tengo yo no sé puede ser
cualquier elemento vamos a decir que
tengo un elemento llegué aquí como lo
puse en él
en esto entonces tengo yo y estoy
suponiendo como cumple la ecuación que
es igual a una a efe de alguien de algún
x ok entonces este x
mandará por acá entonces quiere decir
que al aplicarle efe a este x
esto es digamos aplicarle f
entonces al aplicarle esta fx queremos
preguntarnos si existe una única
solución para esto necesitamos repasar
un poquito que es que fs invertible que
fs invertible significa que existe una
función que definimos como la inversa de
f que vaya a de gea x ok que vaya de iu
a x y sea tal que tal que cumple dos
condiciones es verdad que f
a la menos uno bueno la inversa de f
seguida de f no es otra cosa más que la
identidad en x y aquí podemos podemos
hacer un dibujito por ejemplo si yo
tengo un punto a ok
tengo aquí un punto y que primero aplico
efe verdad primero aplicamos efe
entonces iremos a dar algún punto
efe de a efe de ahora después de
aplicarla efe vamos a suponer entonces
que existe la inversa y por lo tanto
puedo yo regresar el regresar me implica
que esto no fue otra cosa más que la
identidad en x es decir empecé en este
punto y al aplicarle la identidad queda
en ese mismo punto lo mismo pasa si nos
vamos primero allí con efe y luego a x
con efe al menos 1 ok ahora también
tenemos esta condición que f seguida de
f la menos 1 es la identidad pero en ye
y de eso podemos hacer un dibujito por
ejemplo aquí
acá arriba ok entonces tengo yo algún
punto
que al aplicarle efe ala -1 vamos a
algún punto en equis y después al
aplicarle efe pues regresamos al mismo
punto dándonos aquí la identidad en ok
entonces la pregunta que tenemos es
tenemos este y qué es
efe es aplicarle efe algún x de hecho
este sería nuestro x muy bien entonces
la pregunta que tenemos es si es esto
único y un ejemplo de donde podría no
ser único es que tal si tenemos aquí un
b y que esto hay una función nos va a
dar a b de este punto muy bien que no
fuera único sería por ejemplo pensar que
aquí hay algún otro punto que después de
aplicarle la función f
también nos vaya a dar a ese entonces en
perdonar entonces esto no es único
estamos pensando que no es único
si pensamos que hay dos puntos distintos
que van a dar al mismo punto después de
aplicarles la función verdad entonces la
pregunta que tenemos es primero si esta
ecuación fx es igual para este punto b
sí sí la pregunta es si existe la equis
ok entonces nos preguntamos si si existe
una solución y además si es única verdad
entonces sí es importante preguntarnos
la existencia porque bueno no tendría
sentido hablar de si es única si sabemos
que a lo mejor no existe pero una vez
que sabemos que existe es importante
saber también si es única la solución o
si puede haber varios ok entonces vamos
a ver esta relación que tenemos digamos
tenemos vamos a utilizar el dibujito
rosa tenemos que fx es igual a ye
entonces tenemos que es fx para algún x
que se encuentre en el dominio qué pasa
si nosotros aplicamos la inversa la
inversa de gm entonces mover esto un
poco qué pasa si nosotros aplicamos la
inversa en esta ecuación es decir qué
pasa si nosotros hacemos
efe a la menos uno de este punto por
supuesto es aplicar efe a la menos uno
de verdad entonces por un lado vamos a
tener
efe a la menos uno de iu y del otro lado
podemos darnos cuenta que esto no es
otra cosa más que sea la menos uno
seguido de efe aplicado a nuestro punto
x verdad esto es la definición pero que
sabemos de ésta de esta función inversa
que fue la menos 1 seguida de f no es
otra cosa más que la identidad en
nuestro conjunto x aplicado al elemento
x y la identidad pues es aquella función
que a cada punto le asigna el mismo
punto entonces a donde llevamos es que
ésta
si tiene solución de hecho x el punto x
que es la solución debe ser la imagen
inversa o efe a la menos 1 aplicado a y
verdad
y esto es es único queda claro que es
único de hecho porque sólo sólo hay una
inversa
sólo hay una inversa no puede haber
distintas verdad entonces como sólo hay
una inversa sólo puede ser esta x solo
puede ser
efe a la menos uno de ella por la
unicidad de esta función inversa si
hubiera otra inversa pues a lo mejor si
podría hacer que haya dos soluciones
distintas ok entonces si consideramos
una función que es un mapeo de x allí y
que además es invertible como existe
esta inversa que cumple estas dos
propiedades
podemos garantizar una solución única
para esta ecuación fx igual hay verdad
hay una solución única entonces vamos a
escribir esto ya como una proposición o
como un resultado
y tenemos que sí efe es invertible
entonces entonces a qué conclusión
llegamos llegamos a la conclusión de que
fx iguala y que es una ecuación para
cualquier ye y esto es son para todo
para cualquier ya que se encuentra en
nuestro con en nuestro dominio tiene
tiene una solución única solución
entonces nos fijamos en algún punto de
nuestro dominio sabemos que debe existir
un único x tal que al aplicarle la
función vamos a ir a dar allí ok y de
hecho es el elemento que es la solución
es la imagen inversa de verdad es decir
x es efe a la menos uno de cómo lo
calculamos aquí ok muy bien este es un
resultado muy bonito pero ahora pensemos
lo al revés
vamos a pensar este problema al revés
qué pasaría si por ejemplo yo tuviera
que para todas y para todo y en nuestro
dominio fx
igual ayer tiene una solución única
tiene una solución
única
muy bien entonces vamos a suponer vamos
a suponer perdón ahora lo que obtuvimos
en las observaciones anteriores vamos a
suponer que esto es la hipótesis que
tenemos una solución única ok entonces
la pregunta sería entonces si al tener
una solución única para esta ecuación la
función va a ser invertible vamos a ver
vamos a experimentar un poco digamos que
tengo aquí otra vez mi conjunto x que
tengo aquí a mi conjunto y muy bien
y voy a definir una función que le voy a
llamar digamos s que ahora va a ir de iu
a x entonces esta función es que estoy
definiendo estoy construyendo estoy
construyendo la función inversa de
nuestra de nuestra efe ok entonces qué
es lo que sabemos que dado cualquier
punto
digamos tómense este punto aquí sabemos
o más bien tomémonos un punto en que
sabemos que existe un único x digamos
este sería nuestro x tal que al
aplicarle la f nos va a dar a esto
verdad no importa cuál sea el que nos
tomemos por ejemplo no sé éste si
tomamos otro aquí y otro acá pues sólo
va a haber un punto que vaya a dar a
este otro después de aplicarle la
función f pero bueno
si está definido o más bien si definimos
ese de y nos tomamos un punto y en
nuestro en nuestro dominio bueno en este
caso sería el dominio verdad nos tomamos
llegó un punto aquí en este conjunto ok
y a ese de y le lo asociamos como la
única solución la única solución
evolución por supuesto en nuestro
conjunto x a la ecuación f x igual allí
ok entonces esto a lo mejor tú dirás
bueno a lo mejor éste es una definición
un poco rara y medio medio oscura no sé
pues resulta rara pero es una función
válida verdad si yo tengo como les decía
este punto de aquí verdad ahora yo voy a
empezar a asignar de hecho voy a quitar
esta flecha
si voy a quitarle esta dirección porque
si yo tengo este punto puedo hacerle una
asociación a un único punto de x qué es
lo que caracteriza los a las funciones
verdad cuál es el punto que voy a
asignar en x pues aquel que después de
aplicarle f me va a dar este punto que
me elegí entonces como pueden ver es una
definición válida de lo que es una
función verdad a cada elemento le asocia
un único el elemento en el otro conjunto
en este caso sería a x entonces
vamos a considerar un punto digamos aquí
tenemos un punto b
un punto b y sabemos que después de que
podemos aplicarle ese debe entonces este
de aquí es ese debe muy bien entonces
qué es lo que ocurre que estamos
pensando estamos pensando que ese debe
es la solución la solución única única a
la ecuación de esta ecuación fx me tiene
que dar quien pues ve muy bien entonces
qué significa esto qué pasaría si
nosotros aplicamos
efe efe a ese debe efe aplicado a ese
debe muy bien esto como es la solución
ese debe la solución única a esto quiere
decir que f aplicado a ese debe nos debe
dar b correcto pero esto no se está
diciendo muchísimo muchísimo porque esto
es una composición esto es
efe seguida de ese aplicado a de ave no
es otra cosa más que el mismo elemento b
quiere decir que esta composición
un punto b y le asocia el mismo entonces
no le queda ser más que la función
identidad en el conjunto y del elemento
ve muy bien entonces esto este enunciado
que tenemos aquí el definir a ese porque
de hecho estamos definiendo la inversa
le estamos construyendo es entonces
vamos a demostrar que f es invertible
dando la función inversa entonces ese de
y que es la solución única en x a
nuestra ecuación fx igual allí nos
implica que f seguida de s es decir
definiendo esto así
esto nos implica que f seguida de s es
la identidad en ye y esa es una de las
condiciones para que f sea invertible
verdad
es esta de aquí abajo entonces ya
tenemos una de esas condiciones
necesitamos encontrar la otra así que
vamos a seguir experimentando un poquito
con este tipo de diagramas vamos a hacer
otro dibujito aquí digamos que tengo
aquí mi conjunto x que tengo acá mi
conjunto y muy bien y queremos ver qué
pasa cuando tenemos ese aplicado a efe
de a ok tenemos ese aplicado a efe de
verdad queremos hacer la otra
composición entonces si me tomo a efe a
efe de hecho aquí tengo mi punto a le
aplicamos efe y aquí llegamos a efe de
verdad simplemente es cómo se vería
entonces qué pasaría ahora se aplicó ese
quiere decir que como este feria está en
gel le puedo aplicar ese y esto me
regresa a un elemento que bueno
podríamos pensar que a lo mejor no
estará aunque vamos a ver en realidad
quién es y esto es después de aplicarles
muy bien entonces la prueba
si este s aplicado a efe puede ser algún
otro elemento distinto de a ok entonces
vamos a ver si quienes esto porque s
aplicado a efe de a es la solución única
la solución única única a la ecuación
la ecuación
esta de aquí efe de fx
quien me debe dar pues a quien le
aplicamos la función ese debe ser
efe y realmente aquí no necesitamos ni
conocimientos muy avanzados de álgebra
ni mucho menos simplemente en la
ecuación fx igual a de fedea entonces
quien tiene que ser x quien es x aquí en
esta ecuación pues me cae que tenemos
que hacer
estos dos iguales entonces una solución
pues simplemente es x igualada correcto
pero como la solución es única pues no
le queda o no no tiene otras opciones x
más que ser a muy bien entonces qué es
lo que encontramos
con esta relación de aquí tenemos que s
s
aplicado a efe es igual a a verdad
es igual a a perfecto
si ese después de aplicárselo a efe de a
pues no me va a dar a ningún otro punto
más que en realidad va a dar aa y eso es
lo que obtuvimos o bien que ese seguida
de f aplicado a nuestro punto a es igual
a en otras palabras que s seguida de f
resultó ser nuestra identidad en el
conjunto x muy bien entonces repasemos
un poquito qué fue lo que hicimos
queremos ver ahora la contraparte es
decir si suponemos que esta ecuación
tiene una solución única para cualquier
punto que nos tomemos en nuestro en el
co dominio de la función f entonces al
definir nuestra función es de esta forma
rara que a lo mejor parece que le
estamos dando vueltas al problema pero
en realidad es la forma de definir una
inversa o más bien la inversa de nuestra
función resulta que en efecto tenemos
esta primera propiedad que f aplicado
después de aplicar ese resulta hacer la
identidad en nuestro conjunto
muy bien y eso lo podríamos ver con
estas observaciones
por otro lado podríamos ver que ese
seguido de f es igual a la identidad
pero en el conjunto x entonces si
juntamos esta observación y también que
f seguido de f es igual a la identidad
en ye ok
estas dos observaciones podemos concluir
podemos concluir entonces que f es
invertible efe si invertible que
significará que se fuera invertible pues
que si tenemos f que va del conjunto x
al conjunto y es invertible si existe
otra vez el simbolito que existe una
función que llamo efe a la menos uno
creo que la función inversa que va del
co dominio de f es decir va ahora de g
a x que cumple esto verdad efe a la
menos 1 seguido de efe es la identidad
en x y que f seguido de f a la menos 1
es la identidad en esto por supuesto nos
dice como como en realidad tenemos que
la función s cumple estas
características
quiere decir que f no es otro más que la
función inversa verdad entonces qué es
lo que obtuvimos finalmente ya para ir
redondeando todo esto todo en este en
este vídeo empezamos con una función f
que va de un conjunto x a un conjunto y
y que resultaba ser invertible muy bien
queríamos relacionarlo con el hecho de
esta ecuación de tener esta ecuación una
función aplicado a un x que nos da que
si nosotros conocemos realmente esto es
una ecuación y queríamos saber si tiene
una solución única y esto era la parte
primordial e importante de este vídeo y
resultaba que sí que si teníamos una
solución única y de hecho era muy fácil
probarlo era consecuencia de que también
tenemos sólo una
no podemos tener varias entonces después
de eso vimos que no sólo es que la
invertibilidad implica solución única
sino que también tenemos que sí sí para
todo y que se encuentra en nuestro
dominio que sí para todas y en el
condominio hay solución única solo
solución única a la ecuación fx igual
hay entonces entonces
entonces efe es invertible
efe es invertible entonces la
combinación de estos dos resultados no
lo voy a poner ya abajo y como nuestro
resultado grande y final del vídeo es
partimos de una función f que va de x
allí
y que además le pedimos que es
invertible verdad invertible
y esto va a pasar si y sólo si que a
veces en algunos libros lo denotan como
si con doble y ok esto pasa así solo sí
para cualquier elemento en el condominio
df que para esto existe una solución
solución única única a la ecuación a la
ecuación
fx fx igual allí y en realidad este sí
solo si me está diciendo que si f es
invertible entonces voy a tener solución
única y también me dice que si yo tengo
solución única voy a bueno resulta que f
es invertible así que esto fue nuestro
gran resultado que nos llevamos en este
vídeo que la invertibilidad de una
función implica que hay una solución
única de esta ecuación para cualquier ya
que se encuentra en el condominio de
nuestra función y al revés que si
tenemos esta solución única como lo dije
tendremos que f es invertible